Congress is having a big fight with the
president you heard about this right
okay let me tell you that was one of you
one of you knows what I'm talking about
the rest are here for Game of Thrones
which when I'm with you on that by the
way you know Congress is demanding that
President Trump hand over tax returns
going back to 2012 yeah yeah Trump
refused saying the only thing I've kept
from 2012 is Melania yes thank you
that's good enough that was the legal
that was good no now that the president
is refusing to hand over his tax returns
Democrats are considering their options
it's getting serious yeah they have to
they can either issue a subpoena or they
can call them every few minutes and say
come on - uh - thank you - Forrest we're
almost done - force
[Laughter]
hold on he can hang on him for one more
we'll get this thing going right to
forest President Trump to comply
Democrats are invoking a law that goes
way back to 1924 and that cool yeah the
law was written by a middle-aged Bernie
Sanders
[Applause]